welcome to the across the spoiler verse
podcast I feel like we kind of need a
theme tune for that because we're just I
just drop in every week with my voice
and I know if it's going to ruin it for
people just hearing my my dull set tones
that's going to bore them to sleep every
night huge thank you to everyone who
tells me that they listen to me going to
sleep and it really helps them out it's
done Wonder for my confidence and my
voice we're not here to talk about my
crap voice though Greg what we're here
to talk about is how you been I've been
good man I've been good looking over the
list I was telling Paul I need to form
some opinions before we get going crazy
week all together I actually took um my
staff out for a lovely Christmas du on
Friday bit annoyed Greg because I was
sitting in a bar right and I'm sitting
I'm life of the town I'm life of the
soul of the party chatting away about
how famous I am no one's recognizing me
Greg anyway I go downstairs go to the
toilet I come back up they go oh when
you were away the people on the table
next to us they were like is that is
that heavy spoilers lad cuz he looks
different in real life and I'm thinking
now I'm thinking what the hell is wrong
with why why do I look different isn't
my face or something you know what I
mean but that was pretty cool so if
you're listening to this now you could
have made me look good mate and I'm a
bit angry about it that you didn't come
home and be like you make the best
breakdowns ever but it's just one of
those things guys and we appreciate your
comments as always you guys can listen
to us on the go at Spotify Amazon I keep
asking for the likes at the end of the
video you've been here enough times now
you know you know if you enjoy this
podcast or not so just hit the thumbs up
takes one second and yeah that that
makes a massive difference to us um but
Paul do you do you ever get recognized
because you're more you're more of the
voice and your your face pops up on your
breakdowns with your little p cut out
but you're not really on camera that
often no not really I mean I got when we
went on holiday the other week I got
recognized by a guy and I was like do
you want a photo and he was like no I'm
off um but I'm guessing you get
recognized quite a lot because you're
obviously I mean I would recognize you
if I saw you and I didn't I don't even
watch your videos just unsubscribe from
them all yeah you're like you're that
hack Channel aren't you it's usually
what I get I recognize maybe like once a
month I get I mean there's a couple
people at the at the gym who who know me
I hope they're not watching now because
90% of the time I'm like I can't really
have a conversation because I'm in a
rush and I don't want to be rude but if
you start talking to me I'm gonna keep
talking to you because I don't know how
to get out of a conversation so you you
don't go to that gym anymore just taking
off gyms in the city like can't go there
anymore can't go there anymore cuz you
hate your fans we confirmed it guys we
finally got them to spill whereas I'm
like come over and make me look good
Greg's like I'm never I'm don't speak to
these people they're scum but uh it's
been a quite a strange week at the box
office Greg as always we start off with
the box office numbers so the boy and
the heron that is number one this
weekend it's gross $10 million in the US
number two still holding strong The
Hunger Games The Ballad of song birds
and snakes that's done 9 million in the
US bring its total to 135 million and
number three something I could have been
saying right now but we're recording
instead that is Godzilla minus one which
has done $25 million in the US but
apparently it's done 51
worldwide yeah oh I'm I'm pretty devast
um I was told on Friday I was getting a
screener for it and the pr guys just
disappeared so we like can we have the
screener now please like nope not
telling you so I'll probably go try and
see it um it was a special screening
tonight just the one showing but it
comes out officially on Wednesday so
whatever happens I will go and see it
then guys and uh yeah very very excited
to see it on the big screen because been
hyped up a lot and I am I'm I'm very
very excited to see it um but Wonka is
also out worldwide for some reason
reason it's not out in the US but I've
heard really good things about it um and
Luis Fernando who always brilliant
Twitter account definitely go check him
out he he brings in amazing box office I
mean there was a time when he was
reporting on how badly the the Marvels
was doing he was getting loads of people
being like you're scumbag you you you're
a hater but he's just the numbers don't
lie um so definitely go check him out
and he always provides what I think is a
very balanced take on stuff and he he's
been talking about onek that has crushed
the industry projections and it has
scored a
43.2 million 5day opening overseas with
just 37 markets the Brits ate it up
according to Louise with an estimated
11.1 million over its three-day weekend
wow yeah very very good was projected
just to do 30 to 35 but 43 and I think
that's through Good Word of Mouth I've
heard nothing but good things about this
film um my editor Matt went to see and
he he came out you what he does is he'll
post some it's like kajima well he's
like a normal person who tells you that
they're going to see something and then
they give you the review after but you
know kajima will sometimes post that
he's going to see a film and depending
on how lengthy the the responses after
the movie that let lets you know all you
need to know but he said it was
brilliant um so yeah it's good I don't
know if I'm going to cover it on the
channel because I just don't know if
it's a sort of thing we would cover but
yeah it's it's it's doing well for
itself now Greg we need to switch back
into hater mode let's do it you you to
be angry that women exist Greg um
because the Mars when were talking about
that box office again um but it's
actually because Disney have put out a
memo saying that they're just going to
put an end to reporting on the box
office for the Marvel which is quite sad
like it's clearly flop and I think it's
a shame you know I didn't I I gave the
movie a six out of 10 I think it was
kind of that level for me I know it
means a lot to some people um who wanted
and there are some people who wanted
this to do well so I'm not going to dunk
on it um but it's a shame for those
people I guess that it's it's
underperform like this um so yeah Disney
have just put out a memo saying they're
going to stop report reporting on the
numbers I'm guessing why this is is
because every weekend since its release
there's been a new report saying the
Marvel's bombs it's the lowest grossing
MCU movie of all time it's worse than
morbius and the only way to control that
PR is to basically do this I personally
feel that they're just picking and
choosing because if it was doing well
you know they're happy with those
numbers getting out I feel like the
numbers should come out either way but
what are your thoughts
Greg um I really don't have strong
feelings on the matter it just makes a
lot of sense to me that they would do
this it sucks that they can control the
narrative that they're trying to take
control of a narrative but this only
weakens the this doesn't give them
strength this make them look weaker in
in the end of it because we all know
whoever learns about this or follows
this kind of news immediately goes well
it's because Disney's been been
lately they haven't been great it's not
just the Marvels you know it's it's been
it's the end of the year is this their
last big release the Marvels this year
wish wish was wish oh another one
another one that didn't do well and that
was like touting as the 100th
anniversary or something special about
it
so if you look at the combination of
just EV most movies and shows they've
had this year as everything's been like
underperforming or at the box office
theatrical release is not doing well
we're going to talk I think we're going
to talk about like possibly them doing a
Mandalorian movie which I have a little
bit more opinions about than this and it
just kind of goes in hand with like ah
Disney
you and then on top of that too their
their leader Bob Iger is is every time
he just says something in the new it
just makes things worse so this to me is
just another sign of yeah they they know
they know things are bad and now they're
trying to yeah hide it so they're just
waiting for their Splash moment when
they could have something big if what if
comes out I think it's Market
manipulation really isn't it because
obviously this is going to affect the
the stocks so they're just keeping it
out the stocks they're going
everything's fine guys don't look back
there at the numbers it's all going
great you just everyone knows though
everyone knows the stock people they all
know they're all having their secret
it's like sometimes we get the meeting
we hear we hear what goes on in the
meetings but I imagine there's more
meetings that we don't hear about where
it's just like fraught the entire time
and everyone can see through the
Paul you just deleted all the
notes on the Google on the Google
Document how am I supposed to know what
we're talking about when you delete
notes in real time Paul you keep this in
because you just read the next thing but
because we're already talking about the
thing that we're talking about right now
and then the next thing that we're going
to talk about about is what is at the
top of the document Now Greg that's how
I transition man that's how I've M with
the art of transitions
today well I think after that terrible
transition people are going to have a
Deadpool about you Greg and that takes
us into our main story Deadpool 3 uh
Ryan Reynolds has put out a statement
basically saying please don't leak the
movie um and I was just wondering Greg
we could talk about it here are leaks a
good thing or a bad thing so Ryan
Reynolds I'll read the statement he's
put out surprises are part of the magic
of theatrical movies it's important for
us to shoot the new Deadpool film in a
real natural environment using practical
effects as opposed to making movies
indoors and digitally telephoto lenses
continue to spoil the surprises and
create a difficult situation for
everyone which is mean I take my Ryan
Reynolds in ejection there not cool guys
here's hop some of the websites and
social channels hold back showing images
before they're ready the film is built
for audience joy and our highest hope is
to preserve as much of that magic as
possible for the finished film in the
big screen part of the reason people
post spoilers is because they're excited
I realize these aren't real world issues
and it's firmly in the good problems
bucket I love making this movie it's a
quite a respectful post he didn't come
out and say I hate the fans like you do
and sometimes we see some actors doing
but we know he does he does he's worse
than me I know that for a fact but it's
a problem that we talked about last week
and I was I was genuinely thinking how
are all these Deadpool 3 leaks getting
out have they got Daredevil working on
security or some because I mean you
can look at the photo and see where the
angles are and where it's being taken
from and you know if you if you've got a
good security guy you'll be able to
figure things out but he's basic and
what he's done on top of that he's made
a joke out the situation so you you guys
have probably seen where he's posted
images Where will Deadpool are standing
with The
Predator um they've got walking away
with money from Mickey Mouse there's
loads of them and it was quite a fun
thing and you might actually remember
the first image that leaked of Deadpool
in Wolverine uh that did seem like it
was almost a leak in itself the way that
image was cropped and shot and I feel
like that was going to leak and they
tried to get in front of it by being
like okay well it's out now so we're
just going to post it on our social
Channel because I remember when it
leaked we were kind of going back and
forth of are we allowed to report on
this or not because the way YouTube
Works guys is that basically you can
you're allowed to talk about something
that you've seen But if you show it
that's breaking copyright and it's not
actually officially out there so even
under fair use laws it won't be
protected so a lot of the times for for
example when endgame leaked um I did a
video showing some images from that
instantly got taken down off the
internet and then uh basically re-edited
the video but it had the same audio and
I didn't use any images I just used sort
of comic book shots and stuff and that
was fine so I think they try to get in
front of it there but yeah the these
shots have obviously been shown in
newspapers at this point and it's more
widespread than just being something
someone on YouTube leaked yeah so yeah
Greg what reading that statement what
were your thoughts
I mean I think Ryan Reynolds he handled
it the best he could like he didn't do
it in a way that was aggressive and I
liked what he did too to bring it back
to a sense of levity the way Ryan
Reynolds does because we don't want
serious Ryan Reynolds out there so when
he did those joking photos to follow I
thought that was a really great call now
when it comes to the question or leak's
good or bad wait there were jokes I made
20 videos on those thinking they were
real no they were they were some people
did actually predator going to be in
this movie what um but I I thought I I
think that when it comes to our leaks
good or bad it always depends on on the
leaks um because some people are really
in the camp of no leaks ever right
sometimes leaks really do build hype
when it came to Spider-Man no way home
the leak that whole movie practically
leaked before it ever came out but there
was also so many additional ridiculous
leaks that you're like there's just no
freaking way that that's true but it got
to the point where when you look at no
way home just how many leaks had come
out
that some of us were going there's just
no way any of this could be true for the
fact that we even got what we got in no
way home was was mindblowing enough to
the point where it didn't matter that
some of this information came out now
when it comes to Deadpool 3 there's some
elements of it where I think are
beneficial because after no way home
when we got movies like Multiverse of
Madness the theories and quote unquote
leaks were um so so so ubiquitous at the
same time it did not live up at all to
the hype that that that was spreading
everywhere like wildfire on the internet
right and Deadpool one and two have
never had this level of like theorizing
or you know what to expect or what what
gamechanging stuff can they do with
their Universe in Deadpool one and two
Deadpool 3 is the first one of the
franchise be doing that and one thing
about the leaks has been it looks like
it's going to live up to the promise of
that that there will be some craziness
there will be some game changers so for
anyone who's ever felt let down by MCU
as of late for not delivering on the
goods that they want Deadpool 3 looks
like it's going to be honoring that
promise that being
said with Spider-Man no way home what
did we get we got like Andrew Garfield
in front of a blue screen which is a lot
lot of people didn't want that and we
got the John campia photos a lot of
people didn't want that the the Deadpool
3 ones are a bit they're like I don't
want to go into the specifics of what
they are even though most people know
what they are by this point they they
are very revealing of like plot points
that will happen they are they are
extremely revealing and I and I love
that they are shooting this on location
because a lot of the time when you shoot
on the volume or these green screens
they don't look real so I love that this
is going to look real because they're
shooting on location um but they do need
to up their security because it is
getting to the point where some of these
leaks do feel like they are robbing from
The Experience even for myself who's
kind of used to leaks and spoilers I I
I've been like man I didn't I kind of
wish I didn't know that I kind of wish
it just didn't pop up in my feed like
this this like okay if you're going to
tell me this character's coming back
like cool you're going to tell me what
happens to this character damn it you
know like when when stuff like that
happens it's a little too much for me I
mean I I even heard about like about
Aunt May uh in no way home uh like many
of us did what but but when it happened
in the movie um because of how it plays
out there it it still was so effective
with some of these other characters who
are just cameos you know it's not going
to be as long gestating in the film so
it it depends I I would say if a leak is
good or bad sometimes it helps sometime
and sometimes it builds hype sometimes
it helps solidify like oh if this is
what we're getting what more could we be
getting and then other times it does
cross into a line of of uh yeah you are
now you are definitely kind of ruining a
lot of the experience to the point where
Ryan Reynold come out and actually say
something you know I think as well with
Twitter people don't have spoiler
etiquette like we've grown to have Greg
and a lot I know sometimes we'll post
thumbnails that might allude to
something we try and keep that as
spoiler freeze but sometimes I go on
Twitter the reason I learned about a
character being in Deadpool 3 and them
getting killed is because I went on
Twitter and it was like the top post was
that yeah and stuff like that I can yeah
I feel like that's not really um fair
and you if you you should have the the
consent to spoilers I'll say to opt in
if you want to you want to know what
they are um I think you know leaks in
general there are like you say they can
build hype for example no way home is
the perfect example of how Sony just
didn't have to do any real marketing for
that movie but the hype was so big
because we'd heard so much about what
was going to be in it and I kind of go
back to I think leaks are okay if you're
saying them and you're not out and out
proving it now a lot of the time when
you hear about leaks there's a big crowd
of people that will be like that's not
real that's and I'll be like look M I'm
telling you this apparently this happens
in the movie and they'll still have that
doubt but if I bring out a photo or like
you know and show that it's there fair
enough there's still people who are like
Andrew Garfield said he's not in it and
I believe him and it's like well they've
made a 4K video like yeah but it's a
deep fake and it's like do you realize
how expensive this deep fake would would
cost some this would be the best deep
fake technology in the world and we're
not there yet
um yeah I think that there are different
levels to leaks as well and if I think
if there's interest in a project then
leaks massively help out uh I don't as
big as the spoilers for this scam I
don't actually think the spoilers for
Deadpool three that we've had so far are
that big I just looking at the way
things are in it and the way that
Wolverine's acting with Deadpool and so
on I feel like this is at the midpoint
of the movie and it's at a point where
it's kind of the second act they're in a
desolate landscape which yeah I don't
know why you need to film the location
for that because endgame was filmed that
final battle in end game was filmed on
Set uh on like green screen and stuff
and it it pretty much looks the same as
this but they've decided to go to a
quarry um and film a location there yeah
it it feels like this is kind of in the
middle and we're just sort of getting
cameos so I feel stuff like this isn't
as bad as it could be if it was like
third a stuff then fair enough but
seeing that that guy getting beheaded it
did suck but it's just one of those
things it was just like we have to uh we
have to encourage the community to dial
back on how like you're talking about
spoiler etiquette so like that that's
just my point about what we're what
we're discussing is the this does feel
like midpoint act and a lot of people
wouldn't want to know the midpoint Act
of how these things are going to
progress because you and I know
structures of movies well enough now to
the point where we can see stuff like
this and go well yeah this I'm I'm 100%
with you that this is probably like
middle of act two that we're watching
here um yeah but that we had to we had
to like give a heads up to go hey maybe
we if if the leaks still keep coming out
we got to be more conscientious about
how we present this you know the
Fantastic 41 for for Multiverse of
Madness uh not the Fantastic the John
krinski uh moment spaghetti spaghetti
krinski that got ruined for me moments
before I watched the film I was just
like just
going someone just shouted the
every yeah when you said moments before
I was like literally before this scene
happened no walks in I was just on
Twitter and then the photos were there
and I was like what the hell the the
movie hasn't I was even at the I was at
the premiere when it happened I was like
what a weird place for this to happen at
um yeah yeah so sucks it does it does
bum me out but like you said I think
leaks have to be in that terrain where
you're still questioning whether or not
it's going to happen or if it's true
right you have to be kind of in that
head even with the campia photos of of
Toby Maguire we were still dissecting
going these might not be real though you
know like more questionable than the
Andrew Garfield footage we were going
this might this may not be real this may
be I'm not sure I'm not sure this could
be fake and you got to just kind of have
your mind set there because even when I
watched no way home I was still there
going what if Toby Maguire doesn't show
up you know like what if what if he
doesn't actually appear in this movie
you got to have that little bit of a
doubt but photos like this go well we
know for sure this is gonna happen well
I remember even texting you cuz you saw
no way home before me and I remember
texting you on the morning and being
like was Andrew and Toby in it and I
remember your reply I remember it you
said what do you think
and but I know I know now that you were
saying like oh yeah what do you think
yeah of course they were but you just
said what do you think and then you went
to bed so I had about eight hours
doubting myself going oh crap maybe
maybe they're not maybe they're not
maybe I've made a fool of myself saying
this for months but sometimes Stars
themselves they'll they'll leak stuff
like the rock it's a perfect example
because when Black Adam came out about
the week before he's like well I don't
want to get you guys too excited but
someone's coming back and then would
play like the Superman theme tune or
something and have them like so so we
did kind of know that and I think at the
right Point like no way home again I
think at the right Point leaks can
really help sell a movie but it's kind
of gotten to the point now where I mean
I know I know that you've had
conversations with Studios where they
say it's more about kind of like what
happened with one division where people
were speculating so much and so many
fake leaks were coming out and it was
getting people excited for what was
going to come and then when that didn't
happen you know when alucino as Mesto
didn't show up in episode 9 and dror
strange even though he filmed stuff he
didn't show up in episode 9ine but we'd
all heard this stuff and you know Mesto
wasn't in it and when it got to that
point I know the studios were like yeah
we think people are kind of disappointed
with things so we're going to try not
leak things anymore but even then I
think that people cannot help themselves
and they will run wild with stuff and go
crazy no matter what and the perfect
example is Maria Rambo in Multiverse of
Madness clearly in the trailer and you
guys all remember it the amount of
people who were like that's Tom Cruz
Iron Man that is Tom and I was I was
telling them I remember Ryan ER put out
a video saying it was Jonathan Maes say
k he did a big thing saying we've now
got the photo in 8k we can look at it
and it's Jonathan Mages as iron lad or
something and I was telling everyone I
was saying it's not it's Maria Rambo
look at the hips don't lie the hips
don't lie mate shakiro was right that is
not Tom Cruz so even then when we had F
when we had a clip of Maria Rambo as
Captain Marvel and I was saying look
guys this is what's happened I've heard
from plot leaks that Maria Rambo is
basically Captain Marvel in an alternate
universe people were still like n you're
lying it's Tom Cruz that is we got you
Paul so I think that no matter what
there are people who will still imagine
run wild with theories and I think it's
excitement I think and and also like
even recently the Marvel's you know
marvel weren't out and out saying this
is the Xmen are going to be showing up
in this but there was a hell of a lot of
teasers where it was like leave that X
on screen just three seconds longer
three frames even just to tease
something's coming um so I think that
studi they kind of do want to have their
cake and eat it I'm guessing that
something big is going to be happening
in that quy at some point and maybe Ryan
Reynolds is just kind of like or maybe
just knows that like it's getting to the
point where that they giving away too
many surprises like one of the one of
the characters that showed up in those
leaked photos I was like oh man that
would have been cool to see in like for
the first time on the the cinema screen
stud the way how we talked about uh
Studio like Disney picking and choosing
to release numbers they pick and choose
their when it comes the leaks as
well if they don't have faith in their
film actually performing well they're
like we need to leak some you know
we need we need like Dwayne Johnson talk
about Superman being in the post credit
scene we need to completely change our
Marvel's trailer and let some get
out you that whenever they have no faith
that's when they decide we gota we gota
spoil some stuff when they when they
have faith they're like what is the
community doing you're ruining the
experience for everyone so yeah they
pick and choose man and um if Deadpool 3
is not tracking well which I'd be super
shocked if it's not I'd be so surprised
if if it happens to not be tracking well
you know they're going to leak some
extra just because they want to get
some butts and seats but it doesn't work
still doesn't really change anything
when when Studios decide to start
revealing stuff it doesn't change jack
though people do not show up more
because of it yeah I mean it's got a I
don't think there's there's no DC movies
next year it's the one Marvel movie out
next yeah unless you count Sony
Spider-Man spinoff movies but it's it's
dead Deadpool 3 has pretty much got a
clear run of next year other than Madame
Webb and Venom 3 but and Craven Hunter
of course well who could who could
forget but Deadpool 3 has a clear run
next year um I think that they're like
kind of they want to keep control of it
um but back to the original point I
don't actually think there's a right or
wrong answer for whether leaks spoil
or make something you know if they're
good or bad and I think depending on
what kind of person you are you're going
to have a different reception to them
there's some people who will hear leaks
and just be like like even I remember
when Avengers endgame came out Greg and
I didn't end explain on it didn't put
any spoilers in the thumbnail um but the
title was Avengers
endgame ending explained and no
post-credit scene or something like that
basically somewhere I mentioned in the
title that there wasn't a post-credit
scene people are hitting me up like
you've ruined it you've told and I'm
like no I'm trying to save your money
mate I'm telling you that don't stick
around until the end but people
depending on different per people
they're going to have Define for
themselves what a spoiler is and even
things like I'll do an Inception
breakdown you know from years and years
ago and people will be like you put
spoilers in the thumbnail I'm like well
mate you clearly weren't rushing to see
it you know what I mean it's been out
for a while you could have seen it by
now and yeah there's people who Define
for themselves what a spoiler is now if
I can chime in on this trailers whenever
I remember no okay no way home is the
one that's coming to mind because we've
been talking about it no way home when
that trailer came out right the
thumbnail on the Sony one was of doctor
strange and Spider-Man but then all the
other thumbnails for trailer sites was
was like Doc O or Green Goblin I put out
my trailer reaction like an hour and a
half two hours after the trailer already
millions of views and the and I had like
Doc O or I think it was Doc O or green
go one of them was in the thumbnail
right one of one of the main characters
and people are like can't believe you're
spoiling this for us I was like what the
this is the trailer this is the
actual marketing company and I'm being
told I'm spoiling something for you guys
like no screw that there are people who
get very very sensitive about that it's
at that point where like you shouldn't
be on YouTube if if you're going to be
in that situation you know
you shouldn't be checking Twitter before
Multiverse of Madness if you're just
about to go on to see it I know idiots
out there idiots yeah but everyone kind
of defines their own enjoyment and I
think your personality defines whether
you enjoy leaks or not there's going to
be some people who actively seek it out
you know the Marvel Studio spoilers
ready that's got members on it who will
check that every single day no matter
what to see what's going on and there
are people who will actively seek this
stuff out the people do who don't want
to see this stuff I don't know how the
hell you exist on the internet because
the amount of times that you're going to
get stuff spoiled for you here it's it's
going to happen frequently and I pretty
much ever since the um the release
schedules of Disney plus stuff changed
I've St I've start going on Twitter and
like the first thing I'll see is
something being spoiled I'll be like
Batman in The Dark Night Rises when he's
like so that's what that feels like
because I used to have that all at
myself CG I used to used to be shown at
8: a.m. and then I'd have Free Run of
that episode but yeah I think whatever
goes down I I don't think that the
Deadpool leaks these are going to be the
last we see of them yeah I've even been
asked are you g to cover it or are you
still going to cover leaks and yeah
possibly you know if something's big
enough but I'm gonna let you guys decide
whether you want to watch the video or
not we'll just say that so yeah unless
Ryan Reynolds shows up in my house he's
like hey Paul don't do it please don't
do it and I won't do it Ryan if you if
you show up directly to my house um but
in other Marvel news we've got a blade
game was announced at the game awards
don't know if you saw Greg but it was
pretty much just all it was an award
show without any award speeches because
every 30 seconds or like cut wrap it up
wrap it up get off but in between that
we got the blade trailer and yeah it
looks looks all right it's difficult to
tell off these sort of teasers what the
game is going to be like it was the same
with the wolver one sorry the same with
the Wolverine one the other the other
year but yeah what were you thoughts on
the first look it it looks
cool it's
not have it thanks for checking out the
video
exclusive it's I'm excited that we're
getting a blade game it's kind of it's
kind of Nar I didn't I didn't know
anything about them developing I thought
you did reactions for a living Greg yeah
and I didn't for this one I was like I'm
okay um it's mainly been movies lately
but this game it's I mean it's from it's
from be how do you say them bethesa
Betha do you know how to say them Paul
bethesa
bethesa I've never bethesa always
question myself on it bethesa and
they've done a bunch of big games like
Elder Scrolls and Fallout and other
things listed on my computer like
Dishonored that's Arcane lion oh no they
worked on that too Dishonored and uh
yeah there's been a lot of huge games
death Loop these two companies so
they've done a lot of M like a massive
company Greg they're they're massive man
they've done big games that people
really like games I've never played so
you know I'm you sound now like whenever
I get in a taxi and someone asks me
about football or Newcastle I can
totally Wing a conversation about it and
be like be like oh did you see the game
last night and I'll be like oh yeah oh
what do you think you know it was it was
close it was close uh it's a shame but
you know it uh you know what I mean they
be like oh yeah so so who's your
favorite team be oh well at the moment
I'm kind of just looking back and for
you know I'm I'm obviously loyal to the
people where I'm from and that's what
you sound like at the moment Greg you
just sort of talk out your eyes
you've never played a game in your life
you're like sounds how spell how do you
spell bethesa you spell that sounds way
better than anything I just said I'm
reasonably excited for it when do we get
it reasonably excited that's such a like
mild take on something it's like I am
excited with a certain reason notna act
like I'm pumped about it um might it
could be it could be fun who knows it
could be boring as uh if we didn't
really get anything from it um but I
guess what what will be the variety of
the game is he just GNA be like fighting
the same vampires and stuff I I don't
know I would like to see some gameplay
before I get jacked about something in
theory in theory it sounds Grand in
theory it sounds Grand I'm not like down
on it I just don't have again before we
filmed I was like I need some opinions
because I got no strong feelings about
like so much of what we're the leak's
question I had more strong feelings
about than this this thing's like yeah
could be fun could be fun yeah well I
think yeah I think it looks good I've
been aching for a blade game ever since
the Blade 2 and the PS2 um I think it
was Blade Two it might have been blade
one it was one of the blades but uh yeah
I quite enjoyed that used to cut the
vampires yeah and the disintegrate and
at the time those Graphics it was like
whoa what it's set in Paris which is
quite a cool setting for it um it's
going to be weird if this is actually
released before the blade movie comes
out yeah I mean who knows what's going
on with that and Maha Ali said that it
he's read it and he's enjoying the new
script but it's like well yeah I mean
he's kind of down to the wire with it
almost I don't know why he's down to the
wire I don't know but it feels like it's
taken a long time and obviously we've
heard rumors that he he might not be
involved in it but anymore cuz he's
getting a bit sick of it which is fair
enough but um yeah that takes us into
our sponsor for the video which is gfuel
he's going to pump you up and get you
excited for what's to come in the next
part guys yeah man gfuel helps see your
focus your energy help you don't crash
when you take it I've been drinking it
every single day for the longest time
and every month I'm also asking for an
obnoxious amount of cans every host that
comes on real rejects they now get G
deliver to them because I got sick and
tired of them asking me for my G fuel
when I'm like I only have a certain
amount and I need to have them at least
once a day so guys if you want to get
20% off select tubs you could use the
code at the top of the description box
and the pin comment in this one helps us
support this podcast helps keep us going
and and I would really love having this
relationship ongoing because filming
Monday mornings with Paul is not my
ideal time to film and the only thing
that lets me film with Paul is having G
fuel before we film that's so I've
usually drinking G fuel we drinking it
for months on this show before we ever
even got a sponsor with them that's
that's proof that's dedication that's
proof I love them that's absolute proof
it's not like when you pretend to love
computer games but what gfuel does is
that it PR It prepares you for
curveballs like that Greg when I send
you crazy questions that you just can't
prepare for like do you like computer
games and you're like ah talk about
maybe I do I don't know I'm reasonably
excited be Beth fast is a great company
man they're they've done uh the Elder
Scrolls
Online they made made Hi-Fi rush I
totally have heard of this before yeah
star that takes us into our second
sponsorship from
Beast great games will have you
reasonably excited to play will they be
good will it be bad who knows but play
them but yeah huge thank you to gfuel
again what's AR Des I've never even
heard of Arcane lion have you heard of
these guys I don't no I don't think I've
heard of Arcane Studios before I don't
think I've heard of Arcane lion it says
this is made by Arcane lion and Beth
fast and I don't know what the heck
Arcane lion is well I'm making the Blade
game and that's all you guys need to
know and if you want your energy when
you're playing that game you need to go
down to the description click the gfu
link and you'll get that it'll keep you
going through the day mentally
stimulated energy effort we back baby
and that takes us into our next story
which is Superman Legacy casting neptis
is it nepotism is it nepotism neptis I'm
sure you guys saw over the weekend
because uh you're losers you're not out
and about you're on Twitter checking the
headlines and I'm sure you saw what
turned out to be quite a controversial
headline which is that deadline
Hollywood reported that sha gun has been
cast as Maxwell Lord in the DCU now
caused quite a lot of controversy
because even at the moment before this
happened one of the big questions and
criticisms around James gun is that he's
basically just bringing his mates into
the DCU all the characters that are
getting cast in It are people he's
friends with Nathan fillian obviously
was in um Suicide Squad he's now playing
a green lenon J Sean gun was calendar
man um he then played weasel he's
voicing weasel and Cobra Commando oh not
Cobra Commandos Creature Commandos sorry
and uh yeah Shan gun is now gonna be
playing Maxwell Lord so what are your
thoughts on this Greg because oh dude I
got so many strong feelings about this
this is my strong feelings podcast today
I think it's not it's kind of odd that
they're doing this um because it was
Pedro last time right wasn't it it was
Pedro pasc out
and so it was one of the most sought
actor one of the most sought after
actors in the entire world right now
Pedro Pascal he played Maxwell Lorden
Wonder Woman 1984 maybe he just said he
was out though you know just because he
played him once doesn't mean he wants to
come back um but yeah it is a bit of a
do you think they're gonna be I want I
would do want to say the Shan gun
subject but I did hear that they are
going to be recasting Supergirl because
Sasha is not going to come back I don't
I don't know how to pronounce her last
name uh she's not coming back and they
when they want to get a white blonde
girl and then now we're getting sha gun
as Maxwell Lord do you think there's
going to be the backlash the expected
thing about lack of diversity casting
and going back to maybe people I mean if
he casts his wife as Supergirl because
she's white woman then that would be so
funny that would be awesome just
that be the funniest I've ever seen
I would love
that whole time is just acting like
don't know what you guys are talking
about what it's just just the right one
for the
role uh but she's actually a good actor
she actually is uh yeah I mean I I don't
really care enough about Maxwell Lord I
suppose uh to be upset about it I think
sh James gun kind of gets a lot of crap
if the if they weren't people related to
him it wouldn't be as huge of a deal
because
I mean we just saw Oppenheimer and half
that cast are people who worked with
Christopher Nolan countless times right
and well what I think it is Greg is that
often the criticism when you bring this
up with James gun people fire back and
go will score say he works with dairo
and um DiCaprio all the
time Nolan works with kilan Murphy on
several different things I think the
difference is though Greg that well one
they're not related but two they're
often writing original characters and
coming up with new ideas and I think
when it's something like DC where it's
like 8 years established with Batman and
Superman you know it's a big property
and if you get control of it and then
just start putting your mates in it I
think it's a bit different to when say
Martin scor says he sits down to write
good Fellas and and casino and stuff
like that and he starts cing that and
and those people aren't exactly
established with fan bases that are
really passionate you know no one's
going to get pissed off if Killian
Murphy plays Oppenheimer whereas you
know if you start casting your brother
is Maxwell Lord even though he doesn't
look anything like him in the comics and
I personally think it's bad casting um I
think Sean gun's a great actor I think
he really sha during the Guardians
trilogies but you know just thinking of
him as Maxwell Lord I personally don't
see it probably going to prove me wrong
um but personally I that doesn't spring
to mind is someone who when I think
Maxwell Lord sha gun what else has he
done that that you I I I can't think of
anything else Shan gun's been that's not
guard he did that Chris Pratt Amazon
show the terminal list oh he was in that
was he good yeah oh I mean he just Shan
gun really I mean did we see Pedro
Pascal as Maxwell Lord or like when you
first heard that were you like Pedro can
do that yeah well yeah I did I genuinely
thought he was going to do justice to be
honest all right then maybe you're
right maybe I mean I feel like it's it's
like when you you basically when your
mom says make sure you look after your
brother and you're like okay we'll do
and then you get obviously the head of
DC Studios and he just stoed putting
them in everything but he's playing
three people now and a lot of people are
angry because basically James gun made a
a sort of comment in the past implying
that actors would only play one thing
and what they were gonna what their big
plan was to release video games animated
movies films TV shows and they'd all be
part of one continuity where people
would cross back and forth I personally
don't think that's going to happen
because I don't think they fully took on
board how how long it takes to make a
video game but we're going to see if
they prove me wrong um but someone on
Instagram or threads asked him they
basically said not casting one actor to
play multiple characters her you said
not happening and lie detector shows
that and James gun actually repli to
that he said I said very clearly actors
will generally only be playing one
character on screen and said in the same
response that for voice actors it's not
the same like getting into a
wife you didn't hear what I said I said
General I don't know why he responds to
people man like I just wouldn't bother
if was he going to spend all day like
you're the CEO of a big comic book
company you're a multi-millionaire and I
appreciate you taking the time to speak
to the little people yeah but if you
just going to be arguing with people I
don't know if it's very I don't see
Kevin fargy on Instagram arguing people
but we'll see how we'll see how it goes
um but yeah so he brings up the the
actors that have done voices um such as
Sha G Alan Tek Maria balova they'll all
play multiple roles in Creature
Commandos that doesn't mean they won't
play different characters on screen so
what's a need you have and a handful of
others do do desperately need to believe
I'm lying that you seem purposely to
ignore certain parts of what I
said yeah I guess guess so man I guess
he's
right it Al I mean he must have known it
was coming especially when it comes to
Sean anything with his wife who whose
name I slowly for I used to really know
her name before I found out that was
James gun's wife and then I have slow
was it Jennifer
Holland yes am I looking I need to look
that up to make sure but hardc court is
her character not her name right yeah
okay yeah she becomes both she does that
will I saw her on Peacemaker I had no
idea Jennifer Holland right yes you got
it man you're the man you're not sexist
so I was watching her on Peacemaker no
idea that that was not I had no idea
that that was she had any connection to
James gun outside of being an actress in
the show and I remembered being like
this woman is a great actress she's
really really strong she's really solid
and then when it came out you know like
oh they're married and it started
becoming the prevailing part of her
conversation
it's like all good work that she had
done just got thrown out the window and
just oh she only gets work because she's
you know James gun's girl when she's
actually a good actress I think she
she's a good actress but there's just
something about when you when you're
casting I know Tim Burton and when when
Tim Burton and Helena bonam Carr were
together that I don't know why that
didn't bother people maybe because
there's such a unique type of you know
weird Gothic idiosyncrasy to the types
of again I think I think again it goes
back to the legacy of DC I
mean Tim Burton and his wife I can't I'm
sure that she played loads of different
roles I don't think there's any that are
like beloved massive characters that are
part of a big beloved universe that
let's be honest DC fans are very very
passionate about and we'll argue all day
we we've seen that with lots of
different releases every time there's a
new Batman actor announced the internet
goes into a storm and it's only
once that person plays the part that
people are like you know what I was
wrong and it happens every single time
with Batman and that's kind of where I
am with this as well
um I I don't I mean one of the biggest
criticisms with gun is that he casts his
friends and family so you're very much
going to be getting the same same style
and tone to what's been in his other
films um for example got into the Galaxy
volume 3 you know it kind of felt like a
a James gun Ensemble piece of bring and
all his M and
stuff and I can see why the criticism
criticism is there and I think it has
got valid points in it but on top of
that you know against it I I feel that
they often work I mean it's very rare
that I'll watch it I'll be like well
they did a performance and it's
because he cast his friend I think more
times than not and pretty much the
majority of times like we're talking 99%
of the time it works and I think he
knows how to write for his friends so
even though I don't necessarily agree
with it I personally think that it pays
off in the end it's just it's very clear
what the choices are and people who
don't like James gun when they hear he's
taking over this universe they see who's
casting this isn't going to win them
round it's they are very valid in still
being like this is just James gun coming
in taking over and doing his own thing
that I already don't like and I can see
why those people are against it two
credit though I mean Superman is a new
actor Lex Luther someone he hasn't
worked with before Lois Lane on The
Suicide Squad um if I'm not mistaken a
lot of those people he hadn't worked
with before I mean some yes but so I
think that for the bigger leads he's
still going with generally uh actors he
hasn't played with before you know and
it also depends too on who he if he puts
like Michael Rooker or Nathan Vilan
people tend to not they're like
yeah we like them yeah we like I think
it's because they have careers outside
of it though where Sean and and Jennifer
don't necessarily have an established
name outside of working with James gun
th% um they both can act they both you
know are good but it does kind of feel
like oh it's another James gun property
so obviously these people are showing up
which depending on what your preferences
are if you like him I'm I'm sure you're
fine with it and if you don't like them
I see people arguing being like all
these virgins coming out to say it's bad
that he keeps doing this but what about
and it's like well don't call them that
mate they just don't like the same films
you do yeah um and they might not be
excited about the DCU anymore because
it's kind of heading in a certain
direction with James G at Helm I think I
think we have to just wait and let let
it see how you know see how it plays out
it might work out well in the end um
hopefully DC again so there's always
going to be arguments and Zachary Levi
he's actually just recently as in today
but tomorrow when you guys well
yesterday when you guys are watching it
he uh talked about how he he basically
come out and and did a um interview with
comicbook.com where he he brought up how
when your when your brother's in charge
of the DCU you can play who I guess you
get to play you said when your brother
sake when you're the brother of the
guy who runs DC I guess you get to play
who you want and watched the interview
to make sure the context was okay he
seemed a bit salty of course I think
that might be because obviously know
shazam's been Shazam ain't gonna be
heading up no movies anymore I feel um
he's still trying to convince the gods
was a great movie every time he talks
like you know guys it's actually it's
some way it's better than the first
every time he brings it up just let it
go man I
mean I feel a bit bad for him because
obviously they went up against John Wick
for and just got annihilated um but yeah
I I do feel in the industry there will
be that sort of thing as well with James
gun where a lot of actors are probably
like I'd love to work with him but he
seems to just cast like there will be
people who would be perfect for the
Maxwell Lord role who won't get it now
because Sean gun's playing it um who
would you have who who would be your
ideal
casting um alen richson maybe uh from
richer that is more kind of a a muscular
sort of role I don't know if he would be
best served as Maxwell Lord though you
know what I mean I think his height his
build I think he could play like a much
better superhero with superpowers and I
know you know Lords kind of went off
into a multiversal sort of thing at the
moment but personally I would someone
like that not sh basically the opposite
of Shan gun so yeah take sha gun and
then look at the opposite end of the
spectrum and him we're not body shaming
out here I'm a skinny dweeb as well um
but yeah Zachary Levi came out and said
that and you know a lot of people have
been like he's out of line but he's
right and uh yeah it's I think he's kind
of commenting there on how you know if
your brother's running DC you guess you
get to do what you want and the person
basically in the interview brought up
how H Shan gun's played weasel Kender
man and is now playing Maxwell Lord and
it seems like just keeps getting these
roles in DC now yeah well K I mean in
all fairness weasel doesn't talk and
calendar man has like three lines so
it's not really like
massive it's really easy to like kind of
look at that because I I have seen that
going around too and being like this
this already in DC but they're not
they're not like big characters you know
like even like weasel is especially
weasel you know like you don't think
about the performance of weasel it's
just looks like an just a CGI character
is what it looks like to most people
yeah I like weasel though I thought
weasel was great I mean yeah comic
really character best Sean gun character
ever ever ever better than krain so yeah
and I want to hammer home the point guys
I know because I always whenever I
criticize James gun people would be like
it's because you love Zack Snyder you're
SNY bot you SNY shell like I'm more than
happy to give the benefit of the D to
him I'm not saying that the DCU is going
to be Doom and Gloom the main issues
I've had with it are that I I personally
think they just hard reset it um and
that's been that's purely from like
Business Point obviously I do love the
dceu it's just financially I think it
makes sense more to distance yourself
from that universe and I am happy to
prove him wrong so I just want to make
sure that point is Crystal Clear I will
if I want Superman Legacy to be good I
really do I don't want to spend the next
10 I don't want to waste any more time
with a failed DC reboot Universe I want
it to be good I want to be excited about
it and I want to see it s and I don't
want to keep having these false starts
every couple of years where we reboot it
we get someone else in charge and it's
all kind of just the direction is all
over the place I don't want to go
through that again for for another 10
years because it's been 10 years since
Man of Steel and I just wanted to do
well hit the ground running and take off
and do well so I want to make that point
crystal clear as well guys I'm I'm
rooting for the DCU I'm just going in
with a a realistic perception of what's
going on which might make me sound a bit
negative um but speaking of being a bit
negative Greg I don't know if you've
seen But the Mandalorian it's been
rumored that season 4 is becoming a
movie and people seem to be a bit up in
arms about it greck what your thoughts
on it I actually haven't are people up
in arms because I haven't bothered to
look at anyone else's opinion but I do
know my opinion but it's Greg it's Star
Wars fans so you can kind of guess they
don't like
anything uh like me with the
DCU I I don't like this idea I think
it's a terrible idea it sounds like
another homework assignment for
audiences if you're going to do that you
should just keep it's been because isn't
the rumors too that Mandalorian season 4
that they want to like tie in a little
bit more together like get Ahsoka
in there possibly some obi-1 ties in
doesn't even matter at that point you
got three seasons of television and
television show medium they they already
have a hard enough time letting things
properly Pace out and breathe there that
to try to jam a story in a movie unless
your story really requires being a movie
then I don't think you should do it and
my opinion is subject to change
depending on if it's just going to
release on Disney plus if their plan is
to release it
theatrically I think that is not a smart
call I don't I don't feel like it would
do well I feel like it would just be
another movie where it underperforms at
the box office because not enough people
watch Mandalorian season 3 and
especially if they do a SE a Mandalorian
movie that has to have like Ahsoka tians
and whatever and then you put that like
movie out there of course as a fan who
keeps up with all of this I i' be
like yeah I would love to see that movie
there's that other side of me that goes
yeah I keep up with all this so of
course I would love to see it but for a
company a studio that is struggling
right now to maintain its audience and
Who does these Cinematic Universe
crossover films that feel like homework
assignments for a large part of the
audience who does not want to commit the
time to doing the homework I don't think
it's a smart call personally I'm not a
big fan of the idea are you I am and
I'll tell you why and I think we're on
opposite sides of the table um so
Disney's Big downfall at the moment has
been its viewership figures obviously
the Mandalorian season 3 viewership was
down the SOA viewership was down
buckerell Fair they I think they've
realized that the viewership just isn't
there on Disney plus anymore and as much
as they want it to be there's a clear
measured decline going down like that of
viewership on Disney plus so what
they're doing is turning this into an
event and making it a big event where
it's a m it's going to be a movie with
all the brand new Star Wars characters
it's going to be a big crossover thing
you're going to have time to go and
check out those episodes on Disney plus
they're like eight episode Seasons
there's only three of them and even if
you don't know they might help you with
the groundwork it also gives them the
opportunity to bring in you know better
effects for the Aging Luke Skywalker can
come back Han Solo and so on there is a
possibility there both those people have
be both those actors have been deaged
some to better effects than others are
actually watch style of Destiny again at
home the other weekend I had to turn it
off because I was like the the the agen
isn't how I remembered it in the cinema
but also I think I think doing it as a
movie it removes the Filler episodes in
the Mandalorian and let's be honest as
things were getting on there were those
Filler episodes I think when you can
tell just a condensed story two hours
two and a half hours whatever it's going
to be a lot better than the way that
things are slowly coming out bit by bit
because let's be honest we're all aware
of what the Disney plus formula is right
now which is season starts off really
strong couple of Filler episodes in the
middle uh the end it's kind of a whimper
other than Mandalorian season two when
they brought Luke Skywalker in which was
a Perfect finale ly season 2 Perfect
finale ly season one perfect finol other
than that most Disney Plus shows have
kind of followed that so I think doing
it as a movie just being
like look we Lucas film yeah they need
to realize that stuff's gone has
declined by putting it on Disney plus
and Star Wars has become a Disney plus
series now as a whole it used to be a
big massive Blockbuster movie franchise
that sold out Cinemas worldwide
phenomenon and they have kind of made it
decline fan interest Wise by downscaling
it and putting on putting it on Disney
plus so I think the right way to take
things is go back to the cinema make it
an
event Disney viewership Disney plus
viewership it's declined anyway they're
taking a risk by doing this and I
personally believe that it's going to
probably they're going to pull it off
yeah you know like I I guess I just
ultim like I I ultimately I just have a
different perspective on the matter
because yeah I think I think you're what
you're saying I'm like oh dude
everything you're saying is 100% valid
uh it totally is and and I do agree like
man what happened to Star Wars movies
like there's no movies anymore and and
they used to be cinematic events and I I
just have a hard time wrapping I feel
like in in some extent it it can be
another Marvel's situation where where
it's like I gotta watch it sounds easier
said than done of yeah it's just three
seasons of Television for Mando a season
of Ahsoka because right like I think
it's the plan is to get like the Ahsoka
tie-ins um but even if it's just three
seasons of
Mandalorian something just reads like I
don't know if this is the right the
right call to being to going back to I
feel like you can pull it off you can
pull off a good movie uh and and I I
have my hope for it uh at the same time
I think a good movie does more for Lucas
film than a good Disney plus season do
you trust them to do a good movie out of
it when I feel like no com the writing
of how it's been lately just fluctuates
so much and I am there with you like
yeah usually a lot of times it's filler
and then the important episodes often
times you are left feeling with the
important episodes that if you cut out
the filler you could have made the
important episodes even better because
you could have just spent more time on
those important episodes and just made
it feel more serialized and blah blah
blah blah blah so I I just feel like
that even even when it comes to stuff in
Mandalorian season 2 and three there are
people who will watch it going I didn't
watch Clone War so I didn't really know
a lot of this Ahsoka left a lot of
people feeling that way and then I like
how much more would people feel that way
for your movie where it's it's going to
be like a two to two and a half hour
film and then you're GNA have to try to
like Drop Exposition in there of all the
that happened in the shows and
everything and it well make it sort of a
I don't know start off with a new
charact well not you don't need to start
off with a new character start off with
it from the perspective of baby Yoda as
the main character Don't Call Him grou
anymore just call him baby Yoda and have
him grow up through a Mandalorian movie
trilogy and then they can be like well
if you want to learn about what happened
to him as a kid go back and watch those
Mandalorian season but I think that you
know having having him train as a Jedi
having him train as a Mandalorian the
title The Mandalorian can refer to him
and doing it that way okay yeah so
you're not saying conclude the story of
I've been looking at this as a
conclusion of the Mandalorian story
saying like start a new type of movie
franchise with I mean if you're taking
it to the movies yeah you might as well
okay cuz I was looking at is as a as
we're gonna conclude the stories via the
movie and that's where I am not the
biggest fan of that idea personally yeah
and I mean you could even have like a
wish list of stuff that you want to see
in a Mandalorian movie Again Luke
Skywalker Han Solo Boba Fett in it you
can have so many different things in a
big massive movie just get the fans
hyped for it be like we're cutting out
all the Filler episodes that you guys
don't like and take it in that direction
that is how I'd want to see it whether
they do that or not I don't know but I
like their idea
more yeah I think I think the
Mandalorian on Disney plus is pretty
much at a dead end at this point I think
season 4 you're also going to see
declining viewership for that as well so
I think steering it toward towards the
film is the the best way to go about it
do you think people would pay to see the
movie there when already the the
viewership is declining on something
they're already subscribed to depends
what's in it I mean it's a Star Wars
movie it could have lots of different
things in it it could have you know it's
around that time period where you could
start you could have thrawn involved you
could have the emperor being
cloned it's an interesting unexplored
time period in the Star Wars saga that I
think they could do a lot with I like it
man I like I like your hope and I'm
going to feed off of it I'm gonna suck
the te of your
hope well if you like sucking te then
we've got someone's tits who appeared in
The Last of Us Part Two Greg because
there's a scene on that boat where you
see of and that takes Into The Last of
Us casting
news people say I ain't got Segways got
Greg like I don't know what he's doing
right now but I blacked out there just
didn't know what what happened yeah Fant
so Caitlyn yeah Caitlyn diva is
reportedly confirmed to play Abby in the
last of a season two according to Daniel
rpk hell yeah what are your thoughts on
it I thoughts are I can't wait to see
what hijene she gets up to with Joel and
Ellie I know man can't wait I should
play the game and find out because I
just want to live as Joel a lot longer
this is just being in Joel's shoes you
know going out changing those shoes to
golf shoes whatever you want I'm down
down Joel as long as I'm in your shoes
yeah just go clubbing with Joel is what
I would like to do
yeah uh I don't really know her work I
am already concerned for her you know if
you've played the game you you know why
yeah and we know you mean as an actress
as an actress you mean as a person yeah
because as as an actress who is brave
enough to take this on hopefully she's a
w
of what this because I the way how you
know how sometimes we talked about
Batman casting um sometimes when they
cast these actors like I know Ben
Affleck had to have it done um when he
was cast as Batman he was brought in
like look there's going to be a lot of
backlash there's going to be a lot of
happening and um you just got to be
prepared for like they they had to
mentally prepare him for the outrage
that would occur remember people like
it's just so crazy just the backtrack
for a little p how like people love Ben
a like as Batman but a lot of people
forget when he was first cast people
hated that casting so it was
kind of nuts to think about um but for
her I that is kind of like the same
sentiment um from any photo I see of her
on Google I am wondering if they're
going to bulk her up I know that Pedro
does not necessarily look like Joel from
the game and uh to me though you know
Abby her character and the last of us to
the the without going into spoilers for
anything her physicality was the
embodiment of a drive that she had so to
me her being like physically buff female
is is uh to at least for my sake as a
fan I'm like yeah that's that's
important to me that she that the
physicality is achieved like that and
and uh so I hope that happens if not I'm
sure the show Runners are like yeah we
didn't eat it but my main thoughts are I
hope people don't just take out a bunch
of their own crap on her when it's not
her fault at all and it's just fiction
at the end of the day it is just a show
and we've already done it with the video
game like all the the one who voiced
Abby got a bunch of you know so
yeah I'm I'm already like are people I
think people were more attached to
Joel in the game am I saying too much I
don't know am I saying too much I think
people don't spoil yeah yeah yeah
I um I think people yep I'll just leave
it to that I just gotta stop talking
stop talking
people so yeah Caitlyn Diva was in
dopesick that's what I saw her in um She
was recently in no one will save you
which was an alien movie um I think
booksmart as well bookmart bookmart
that's where I know we're from yes yeah
yeah so um I think yeah I think she is a
good actress I really do I think um
she's got really good range to her she
she can play very vulnerable but also
angry as well which kind of Abby needs
obviously it is going to be physical um
it's a very physical role you kind of
have to be bulked up for it whether they
can do that with CGI or muscle suits I
don't know I'm sure they can pad coats
out and stuff and but a lot of the time
Abby walks around with like sleeveless
tank tops on and stuff just stucking
Hench um what they have done though is
Joel it doesn't seem as tough in the
show as he was in the game he's still
very much up that level but they they've
definitely given him some
vulnerabilities for example his death um
he kept having those anxiety
attacks he he's worried and I think
there was a lot more vulnerabilities to
Joel in the show so they've kind of
brought him down whereas they might not
need to meet him on the exact same level
with Abby and yeah when I saw the
casting I was like you know what that is
pretty spot on I think looks wise very
similar facially anyway um and and
obviously she's got time to to bulk up
or they can do something with that yeah
I'm excited to see how it goes obviously
like you touched upon it's going to be
there's going to be backlash to it and
that's a shame because people cannot
separate characters from actors
unfortunately and yeah there will
probably be some some backlash to it but
I I I think they are clearly going to be
doing The Last of Us Part Two I know at
the time when I was talking about um the
end of the last of was part one that a
lot of the comments were like do they
won't actually do what they did in the
games though they're going to take it
and a brand new Direction and I was like
mate they're not they're definitely not
doing that they're 100% taking it in the
exact same direction I can promise you
that um and I think this pretty much
confirms that I love the last of us too
I love that game I think it's great yeah
the remaster is coming out soon I can't
wait to play it in a month yeah $10
apparently if you already have a cop of
the really that's it yeah it's just
an upgrade yeah oh damn so I've got the
steel book for part two and I was like
oh do I really want to sell it and then
I seen the upgrade was just like yeah
put it in the PS5 and pay the little
upgrade fee and you get all the all the
new stuff and I like uh I I
like I know this is not the popular
thing to say but I really like the Abby
character I do and I'm excited for her
to come to I'm excited for her to come
to
I went on a a journey that a lot of
people did with Abby where it was like
hater ha her so much and then I
played as a day one I'm like I
hate Abby day one this is the terrible
and then by day two I'm like you know
what it's good it's good and it gets
better and better as it goes in and you
really warm to that character and that's
what makes it so good when the two sides
fight against each other because you're
invested in both yeah you're like I
don't want anyone of you to die yeah
yeah yeah great I really love I love I I
love her character so much yeah so very
excited going to be playing Through The
Last of Us Part Two again which I'm also
excited for and uh yeah can't wait to do
breakdowns on it that show is going to
be coming in
2025 and House of dragon is going to be
the Big Show for next year and we're
going to be covering it all so very
excited and that's all our stories for
the day guys so thank you for sitting
with us I've had a cold this entire time
but I've been swerving out the way did
not cough down your guys' ears and I
hope you appreciate that and you show
your appreciation by hitting the Thumbs
Up Button Paul has had a viral infection
since we started the podcast every week
he said something honestly don't have
twins guys whatever you do just don't
have twins because one will be ill one
week they'll get through it and the
other one will be ill the next and
you'll just be constantly stuck between
them both getting every disease possible
um but yeah thanks for all your support
as always guys love you so much and uh
yeah you guys make the podcast and make
it worth coming back every single week
to sit through Greg's winging it winging
it he doesn't know anything he's talking
about just like look up I love my Xbox
too
yeah I I love GameCube uh I just go on
Twitter while Paul's talking and go what
are other people saying yeah just say
that James Simmon of uh podcasting but
yeah thanks again guys know we really
appreciate it and hope you enjoy the
rest of your week peacee